- I struggle with social media
and I struggle with just
how much pain people are in.
And if there's one message I
would like to push out there,
you're responsible, everybody, all of us,
myself included, with struggling.
Struggle mightily because
it's nobody else's job
to do your struggle for you.
Now with that said, if you're struggling
and you're trying and
you're trying to figure out
how to better yourself
and where you failed,
where you've let down
your family, your friends,
your workers, all this kind of stuff,
give yourself a break.
If it's not working out, I
have a life-long relationship
with failure and success.
There's been no period
of my life where both
haven't been present
in one form or another.
And I do wish to say that
a lot of times people think
this is glamorous.
I'm about to go do a show with Sam Harris.
People are gonna listen in
two guys having a conversation
onstage, it's completely crazy.
I'm always trying to
figure how to make sure
that those people get maximum value
and that's why I'm doing this podcast.
Just give yourself a break.
You owe us your struggle.
You don't owe your
family or your co-workers
or your lovers or your
family members success.
As long as you're in there and
you're picking yourself up,
recognize that this new
situation with the economy
that doesn't have the juice
to sustain our intuitions
has caused the people
who have risen to the top
of those institutions to
get quite brutal and cruel.
Everybody's lying at the moment.
Nobody's really a truth-teller.
Try to keep your humanity about you.
Try to recognize that if you're failing,
if things aren't where you want them to be
and you're struggling and
you're trying to figure out
what you're doing wrong,
what you could do,
it's not necessarily all your fault.
We are in a global situation.
I have not met the people who are honest,
kind, good, successful.
Nobody that I've met is
checking all the boxes.
Nobody's getting all 10s.
So, I just think that's
an important message
that doesn't get pushed out enough.
Either people wanna
hold society responsible
for their failures,
which is not reasonable,
you have to struggle, you have to try,
or they wanna say you're 100%
responsible for your failures
which is total nonsense.